we just need the stress katie thank you
schiaparelli schiaparelli one word to
describe this look um this look glamour
the fear
uh
says this room is intimidating but my
power
says that this room is inspiring
you are being honored you know i do this
event every year and it always has such
a special energy because it's women
coming together how did it feel to get
the call you were going to be honored at
the power of women events
well
um it's nice to be honored in that way
you know it's been 12 plus years
in the world and in the spotlight and
it's wonderful i got to start a
foundation with my sister too
wait 2018 how many years ago was that i
don't know covent but i got to start a
foundation with my sister in 2018 and to
shine a light on that tonight um is i'm
really honored about and and yeah i
think women lifting up women is so
necessary so important because if we
don't who will
aka texas
godless
orlando was over there he was lifting
you up he seems like oh yes well i think
behind every great woman is a great man
he is an ally he is an ally and i love
him and he handles my crazy really well
i got to ask you about the residency we
are so excited tell me what we can
expect because katy berry does nothing
small
no
actually i might be the smallest person
or thing on the stage it's a
show you can only see in vegas um it's
going to be larger than life i mean it
and i won't ever be touring it and it's
it's really an accumulation and a
celebration of everything i've already
done like it's not the start of a new
era you're gonna get
all the songs that you grew up with that
make you feel good from teenage dream to
hot and cold to you know remixes of
daisies it's gonna be a whole bit sich
it's going to be
a lot of bpm so come ready to shake the
booty and have a couple of cocktails i
gotta say um i think it's happy belated
birthday to daisy and happy early
birthday to you somewhere in between
yeah what kind of celebrations did you
guys have and she's one right i mean
that's a big birthday she's one
i'm just so happy like she's just she's
talking yeah you know she is talking but
she thinks everything is a cat and
you know she says hi gato she says hola
gato
well she says hi gato and so when a
person will walk in she'll say hi gato
and like i don't know why she's so
fascinated with cats which is wild like
the people that love my music they call
themselves katie cats
she doesn't know anything about that she
doesn't care about any of that but for
some reason the
major word in her life is gato it feels
like fate
it feels like destiny